(Seagulls Chirping)
- I'm in Iceland and I am on
one of the most popular
beaches in Iceland,
but it's completely
empty and it's midnight.
But anyway, I want to tell you
about something that I've
learned while I'm here.
And it has to do with hot water.
(upbeat music)
Through a lot of dipping myself,
into a lot of hot and cold water.
What I've found about this,
what I've learned about it.
Is something that's probably
going to change my life.
Let me show you.
- Road Trip
- [Radio] Your in Iceland
- Look ice cream.
- It's still funny.
- Okay. Are we done?
- Then let's get started.
- A long time ago, Iceland didn't exist.
And then these two plates in the middle
of the Atlantic ocean
moved apart and let a bunch of magma
from under the crust come up.
That magma cooled and that became
an island called Iceland.
In other words, Iceland
is sitting on a literal
crack in the Earth's crust
from which a lot of heat
and magma vents out.
And it's because of this,
that this little stream
behind me is super warm.
I'm about to get in it, by the way.
It's warm because there's
heat from the Earth's magma
that is coming up, and making it warm.
The word Saturday, Laugardag in Icelandic
means pool day or hot spring day.
It's literally a part of their language.
And I've been seeing this
as I traverse this country.
Everywhere we go, there
is a pool or a hot spring.
They are everywhere.
There are more pools per capita in Iceland
than anywhere on earth.
And that is because they
love their hot water.
It's not just hot springs.
Iceland uses the fact
that it lives on a crack
between two tectonic
plates to use that heat,
to do a bunch of stuff.
Right now, I'm in a greenhouse
where they use geothermal
heat to grow thousands
and thousands of kilograms
of tomatoes every year.
They're able to grow all
sorts of things that wouldn't
naturally grow in Iceland
because they have geothermal heat
that they're able to sustainably
pipe into these greenhouses
and grow a ton of food.
It's pretty amazing.
Real quick, I want to say
thank you to better help.
Who's the sponsor of this video.
Thank you, better help
for sponsoring the video.
I started therapy about
a year and a half ago,
and it has changed my life.
It's changed the way I
think about everything
and I've become a major
proponent of therapy.
The reason I like better help
is because they are dedicated
to making therapy more
accessible and affordable.
It's a platform where you can connect
with licensed therapists and counselors.
And everything from family
and marriage counseling
to personal counseling.
These are accredited counselors
who you can connect with,
not in person, but over
a digital platform.
The cool thing about better health
is that they help you match
with the right therapist.
Finding the right therapist
is always a tricky thing
and they assess your needs and
assess their giant network of therapists.
And they connect you
with the right person.
And if you don't like your therapist,
you can immediately switch.
You can even message your
counselor throughout the week,
and you'll get thorough
thoughtful responses,
which is really cool.
This service is available
to clients worldwide.
So it doesn't matter where you live.
This is a remote therapy
service that will never
have you waiting in an
uncomfortable waiting room
or lobby ever again.
It is seamless and quick and
tech savvy, which I like.
But really the whole
point is to make therapy
more accessible and more affordable.
So if you want to get
started and try out therapy
go to betterhelp.com/johnnyharris,
that's betterhelp.com/johnnyharris.
Going to that link helps
support this channel,
but it also gets you 10% off
of your first month of better health.
So you can try it out
for a discounted price
and see if it fits into your life.
(upbeat music)
The boys are freaking
out right now because
I just told them that we
are swimming in a volcano.
Which we kind of are.
(upbeat music)
So yeah, Iceland is a place
with a lot of hot water.
It's become a part of their culture,
but is it just because it feels good?
- Yeah it feels good.
- The answer is no, it is not
just because it feels good.
So let's get into this.
Let's talk about what
actually happens to your body
when you immerse it in hot water.
The first thing you have to
understand is that your body
is obsessed with one temperature.
37 degrees Celsius or 98.6 Fahrenheit.
Your body wants to stay
at that temperature,
especially in your core vital organs.
Your brain, your heart,
your liver, your lungs.
It has to keep it at that temperature.
If it goes a few degrees
above or below, you're dead.
And your body has one
really important mechanism
for keeping itself cool,
when it's too hot outside.
Or hot, when it's too cold outside.
And that very important
mechanism is blood.
So let's say you jump
into super hot water,
40 degrees Celsius,
104 degrees Fahrenheit.
Your body freaks out a little bit.
It's like, whoa, whoa, whoa.
This ambient temperature is way hotter
than what we are used
too and what we want.
So it immediately gets to
work, cooling yourself down.
And it uses blood to do this.
It says, get all of the blood
out of this center of the body,
where all the important organs are,
send them out to the extremities.
Let the fingers and the legs
and the calf muscles get hot.
Don't let the heart get hot.
So your heart pumps and your blood vessels
start pulsing a little
bit to push that blood
out into different parts of your body.
Your blood vessels,
literally open up to allow this to happen.
Like they like open up to make it easier
for the blood to get the
hell out of the heart
and out to the extremities.
And it works, it works really wonderfully.
And honestly, it feels really good.
(upbeat music)
If you dip your body
in hot water regularly,
you are giving the body,
a chance to push blood
out to all of these places
that don't get a lot of
blood most of the time.
Mix that with the fact
that these hot Springs
are usually loaded with minerals
that are really good for the body.
And as you soak in them,
you absorb them and that
helps your body too.
So it's no surprise to
me that not only Iceland,
but all sorts of cultures
all around the world
have discovered that soaking
in hot water is a good thing.
(upbeat music)
Water break.
Ready to get some water.
Since we're in an RV,
we don't have tap water and
no one sells water in Iceland.
They don't sell just natural water.
Cause every time I asked
there like you don't need to buy water
just go get water from anywhere.
So we've made it a habit to just come down
to whatever river or creek or stream
we see to fill our bottles.
Yes, please.
Pretty delicious huh?
- Yeah
- See ya
- Okay but this gets juicer.
When I've been going to
some of these hot Springs.
I've noticed that in the corner,
there's always like a
bucket of cold icy water.
We're going in the freezing cold.
(screams)
Henry, Henry James.
At first, I was like, why on
earth would they have this?
And at this relaxing hot spring.
And they have a bucket of cold water.
So I decided to dive into this.
Okay, we've talked enough about
hot water and we all love hot water.
And we know it feels good.
I think it's time to flip the script
a little bit and talk about the other side
of this whole thing.
Which is the part that
I'm literally dreading.
Lets do this.
That's really cold water.
- [Women] Careful
- Wow that was adrenaline.
That waterfall is so intense.
I've been asleep all day
and now I've just woken up.
Like I just see everything
in its true color for the first time.
- To put in to perspective how cold
it is I have a wool blanket
and a puffer and I am still cold.
Like shivering cold so.
- I freaking love Iceland.
Okay so remember that when
you go into hot water,
your body kind of freaks out
and it uses all of these little tubes
in the muscles in your arteries and veins.
To pump blood out to your extremities,
to keep your heart cold.
When you go into cold water,
the exact opposite happens.
Your body still freaks out.
It's like we're going to die
because we are now freezing.
It prepares to save the most
important parts of your body.
It's like, don't care about the arms
at this point, we don't
care about the toes.
Get the blood out of all of those places,
bring them back to the heart and the brain
and the liver and the lungs
keep those alive and warm.
So now all of your little
tubes are flexing and pulsing
and pushing all of this blood
back to the center of your body.
And here's the deal,
your veins and arteries,
don't get to do this very often.
Especially in our modern age where
we're like cozy all the time.
They don't have a lot of practice
pushing blood out to the extremities
when everything's hot and then
pushing it all back to the
heart when everything is cold.
This is sort of like lifting weights
for your cardiovascular system.
You're giving your circulation system
a chance to work out in a way
that it never really has the opportunity
to do when you're like sitting around
cozy all the time in
your nice warm clothes
and nice warm house.
(upbeat music)
Dude its freaking gorgeous.
Boys look at this.
(seagulls chirping)
Alright let's go explore a glacier.
(upbeat music)
I know this is sort of trendy right now.
Cold showers, cold baths, whatever.
Like this is something that
is definitely catching on.
And the leader of a lot of
this is this guy named Wim Hof.
He's like a Dutch Iceman.
He has all these world
records for holding his breath
and running marathons
in the Arctic circle.
Just in shorts and he's
barefoot and all this stuff.
I gotta be honest.
I've been very skeptical of
Wim Hof and his followers
because he sort of has
this guru vibe going on.
Where he's like this
wild, crazy character.
And like he has this wild, new methods.
That's going to solve your world.
However, I started looking into
study after study, after
study, after study.
About cold water and what
it does to our bodies.
And I have to say,
despite my deep skepticism
of Wim Hof is the guru
and his followers as just another
sort of like trendy new
age wellness business.
I'm convinced.
(upbeat music)
It turns out that the benefit
of going into cold water
is actually incredibly well-documented.
Through randomized controlled studies
that have nothing to do with Wim Hof.
They studied people who go
swimming in ice water in Finland.
And found that these
people are way stronger,
more resilient, less prone
to anxiety, depression,
their bodies function more effectively.
And the craziest part,
the one that blows my
mind is they discovered
that when you go into cold water,
your body actually creates
more white blood cells.
The defense cells that
help with your immunity.
So people who dip in cold water actually
have stronger immune systems.
There's absolutely something to this.
And as I've scrutinized
it and looked into it
and done it myself.
I've learned that it's
actually pretty compelling
and something that I
feel like I'm probably
going to start doing
more and more in my life.
The data is there, it's
real, it is very compelling.
And here's the deal.
As I've been here in Iceland,
I've been experimenting with this.
I've been going into cold water.
It's been horrendous,
but it's been amazing.
There's this feeling you
get when you come out of it,
where you're just like in this euphoria.
I freaking love Iceland.
So my little adventure into hot water,
into natural hot Springs.
Into cold water has
been really interesting.
Not just because it feels good,
but because it has really amazing
health benefits that people caught onto.
And that's why they made
it a part of their culture.
Because it helped people live better.